well let's get more detail on the
situation on the ground in ukraine now
i'm joined by retired air vice marshal
sean bell good to see you uh why don't
we start with crimea a lot of activity
there yeah we've seen danny cromer the
third big attack in the last 10 days
targeting jets ammunition dumps military
facilities ukrainians have not claimed
responsibility for it russia has claimed
that there were accidents well in fact
as satellite imagery shows there's been
some very effective precision strikes
against military capabilities on crimea
a lot of concern about this nuclear
plant um uh where's that going
yeah i mean any nuclear facility you
don't want to see um conflict on the
doorstep of it that's uh that's great
news um why the russians have been
involved in zaparica for uh held that
zap reacher for uh the last since march
so why is this suddenly come to the
attention now well the reality is it's
become a hot spot at the front line of
the war with kirsten out to the left
there zap reacher off the right hand
side of the dynapro river and both sides
trading uh artillery blows across the
the pro river worryingly the russians
appear to be their troops hiding within
the russia within their nuclear facility
and then firing outbound from that at
ukrainian troops clearly what the
ukrainian is going to do the temptation
is to fire back which would have grave
consequences international community has
asked for that to be demilitarized
russia have dismissed that out of hand
which is a really clear testament of how
much they disregard and the worrying
risks of having warfare right next to a
nuclear facility of course yeah lots
going on what's the bigger picture
yeah well if we look at the bigger map
here the the war of attrition and that
has been fought in the donbass region
they'll have another slide hopefully in
a moment
but the russians have been making steady
advances uh from the donbass despite
heroic ukrainian resistance but reality
is that unless ukraine somehow gains
gains the upper hand they are going to
lose that as a result what seems
apparent is that president zielinski
decided to focus on down to the south
west down in carson cursor is really
important because the russians hold it
they'll see that as a stepping stone to
odessa and therefore president
zelinski's made very clear he wants to
liberate the person what is the way he's
doing that is he's taken out all the
bridges down the denipro river down here
which stops the russian reinforcements
coming in and he's also been targeting
the reinforcements and the ammunition
dumps in crimea cessna conditions for a
potential liberation the trouble is from
a russian perspective they clearly do
not want to give up person they are
moving thousands of troops down from the
donbass region down to the south that
leaves the donmas region particularly
light in terms of forces and yesterday
for the first time in six months
since the the start of this campaign
there were no territorial gains by
either side as any analysts or either
side claiming them there is still
artillery fire going on probably the
russians just trying to keep the
ukrainians fixed the key point here
though is that ukraine for the first
time is starting to seize the initiative
in this in this conflict there's a
limited window of opportunity for
weather-wise before the rains of the
autumn and the winter come in
therefore and when an off-road and
maneuver warfare becomes very difficult
therefore from eight to ten weeks now
we're expecting to see fierce fighting
as both sides compete to try and get
advantage before the inevitable winter
operational pause yeah and and on it
continues sean thank you